In addition to RSA and
Diffie-Hellman which are the most
widely used algorithms.
There are other public key algorithms.
First, the National Institute
of Standards and
Technology on list, has published
the digital signature standard
It is based on the secure
hash function SHA1.
Note that this algorithm is only for
signature.
Is not for encryption or key exchange.
RSA is the most widely used public
key cartography algorithm for
encryption and digital signatures.
Recently a competing system called
elliptic curve cryptography
has begun to challenge RSA.
The main advantage of ECC over RSA
is that if offers the same security
with a far smaller bit size.
That is, for the same security strength,
it can be much more efficient than RSA.
On the other hand,
RSA has been subject to a lot of
cryptanalysis work over the years.
whereas for ECC, the cryptanalysis
work is still at a beginning,
therefore we are not as confident
in the ECC as we are in RSA.
ECC is more difficult explained
in the form that medical description
is beyond the scope of this course.
But briefly, the technique is based on
the use of a mathematical construct
known as the elliptic curve.
Roughly speaking, two points, p and
t on the elliptic curve are known or
made public.
And p and t have the following
relations, t times p equal t,
under the so called point multiplication
and the fact that d is the private key.
Mathematically, even p and
t, which are public, it is very
hard to find t, which is private.